bro what's up mate gross such a big fan
man Justin Bieber and Tom Holland are
the new besties we never knew we always
needed
likewise bro how are you dude thank you
for saying what you said about my
documentary on Tuesday the yummy singer
and the spider-man far from home star
teamed up for an in s'tel I've and let's
just say people geeked the hell out over
their newfound friendship fans legit
lost it hittin up Twitter writing things
like my life has been completed now
maybe quarantine isn't that bad anymore
and my babies bro what's up mate gross
such a big fan man Justin and Tom kicked
off their chat by totally fanboying over
each other dude thank you for saying
what you said about my documentary they
traded intel on what TV shows to binge
watch we're watching this show cool
what's it cool bro you have to watch
this show what's it called it's called a
loan alone it's about ten people and
they stick them in the wilderness and
have to survive as long as possible and
they updated each other on how they're
doing with this whole social distancing
thing good good I'm really good um just
trying to pass the time you know I'm
getting a little bored but I'm good
same guys Tom also revealed that
production on his upcoming film was put
on pause in the wake of the corona virus
pandemic video game and we showed up for
our first day of shooting and then they
shut us down and I was in Berlin so I
had to come home and now I'm back in
London but guys my favorite part of this
whole thing was Tom having a full-blown
pinch me moment mid chat with Justin I
mean I get it he's the Biebs
this is kind of wild man what is this
got a wild of course Tom and Justin
aren't the only celebs connecting on
social media as we practice social
distance
Miley Cyrus and Demi Lovato rekindled
their friendship on insta live - we
cannot talk forever they'll go down and
like I know that you're the person I
want to reach out to no I said like in
dark times it's really important to
reach towards those that are eliminated
and I just think that you're such a
light and that it's just even if it took
this crisis to get us connected again
without just like we run into each other
at the studio or like some that actually
connected and really talking there's
like so few of us that we just need to
like never let this break again
[Music]